- Witaj ponownie w kursie Zrozumieć Kwantową Informację i Obliczenia.
Mam na imię John Watrous i jestem Dyrektorem Technicznym ds.
Edukacji w IBM Quantum.
To jest siódma lekcja z tej serii i w tej lekcji omówimy problem estymacji fazy oraz to, jak możemy go rozwiązać
za pomocą komputera kwantowego.
Następnie zastosujemy estymację fazy do problemu faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych, który omawialiśmy w poprzedniej lekcji.
Uzyskamy algorytm Shora, który pozwala faktoryzować liczby całkowite
przy koszcie wielomianowym lub w czasie wielomianowym, jeśli wolimy
myśleć w kategoriach czasu potrzebnego zamiast liczby
elementarnych operacji.
To jest korona kwantowych
algorytmów w pewnym sensie i choć faktoryzacja dużych liczb całkowitych
może mieć ograniczoną użyteczność dla większości ludzi, pozostaje jednym z najbardziej
przekonujących dowodów na to, że komputery kwantowe będą
oferować uderzające przewagi
nad komputerami klasycznymi. Oto przegląd lekcji.
Zaczniemy od definicji samego problemu estymacji fazy, a następnie omówimy metodę rozwiązania tego problemu
za pomocą komputera kwantowego.
Będziemy postępować krok po kroku, zaczynając od czegoś, co możesz
potraktować jako swoiste rozgrzewanie.
W problemie estymacji fazy celem jest przybliżenie
pewnej liczby rzeczywistej i w tej części rozgrzewkowej
zobaczymy, jak możemy uzyskać
przybliżenie tej liczby z bardzo małą precyzją.
Nie będzie to wystarczające
do faktoryzacji, gdy zastosujemy nasze rozwiązanie
problemu estymacji fazy do faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych,
ponieważ faktycznie będziemy potrzebować dość dokładnego przybliżenia, ale mimo to warto zacząć od takiego rodzaju rozgrzewki,
żeby poczuć,
jak to wszystko działa.
Następnie omówimy kwestię tego, jak możemy uzyskać większą precyzję, co bardzo
naturalnie prowadzi do operacji zwanej Kwantową Transformatą Fouriera.
Zobaczymy dokładnie, czym jest ta operacja i jak można ją zaimplementować
za pomocą kwantowego circuit.
A gdy już ją mamy, będziemy mogli zastosować
ją do estymacji fazy, by opracować ogólną procedurę rozwiązania problemu
z bardzo wysoką precyzją.
Następnie w ostatniej części lekcji zobaczymy, jak rozwiązanie problemu
estymacji fazy pozwala nam efektywnie faktoryzować liczby całkowite.
A konkretnie otrzymamy algorytm Shora dla
faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych, lub przynajmniej coś równoważnego algorytmowi Shora.
Działa to w ten sposób, że zasadniczo dajemy
sobie kamień milowy, którym jest kolejny problem zwany problemem znajdowania rzędu.
W szczególności zobaczymy, jak możemy rozwiązać problem znajdowania rzędu przy użyciu procedury estymacji fazy, a następnie zobaczymy, jak
możemy faktoryzować liczby całkowite
rozwiązując problem znajdowania rzędu. Zaczniemy od szczególnego przypadku twierdzenia zwanego Twierdzeniem Spektralnym,
a konkretnie skupimy się na tym, co twierdzenie mówi
nam na temat macierzy unitarnych.
Twierdzenie spektralne jest
bardzo ważnym twierdzeniem z algebry liniowej i
analizy funkcjonalnej.
Mówi nam coś interesującego o tym, jak pewne odwzorowania liniowe mogą być wyrażone w pewnej postaci, często nazywanej
rozkładem spektralnym,
który jest użyteczny z wielu powodów.
I jak powiedziałem, skupimy się na tym, co to twierdzenie mówi
nam na temat macierzy unitarnych.
Twierdzenie spektralne jest
ogólniejsze. Nie działa dla wszystkich macierzy, ale działa dla klasy macierzy
zwanych macierzami normalnymi, które obejmują wszystkie macierze unitarne, a także pewne macierze
nieunitarne.
Ale żeby uprościć sprawę, ograniczymy naszą uwagę
do macierzy unitarnych, ponieważ to wszystko, czego potrzebujemy na potrzeby tej lekcji.
Oto sformułowanie twierdzenia spektralnego tylko dla macierzy unitarnych.
Załóżmy, że U jest macierzą
unitarną N na N.
Twierdzenie mówi,
że musi istnieć ortonormalna baza
wektorów psi jeden przez psi N,
wraz z N liczbami zespolonymi
Lambda jeden przez Lambda N, wszystkimi leżącymi na zespolonym okręgu jednostkowym, tak że U może być wyrażone
jak w tym równaniu.
Nazywamy to rozkładem spektralnym
U, jak już wspomniałem, i może być bardzo wygodne wiedzieć, że U można zapisać w ten sposób.
Czasem może być wygodne posiadanie tych wektorów i tych liczb, gdy pracujemy z
konkretną macierzą unitarną U, a może być też bardzo
użyteczne samo wiedzenie,
że taki zapis jest zawsze możliwy, jako sposób na dowodzenie pewnych rzeczy o macierzach unitarnych na przykład.
W tym sformułowaniu twierdzenia każda z tych liczb,
Lambda jeden przez lambda N, jest zapisana w pewien sposób
jako E do potęgi dwa pi I razy theta, gdzie każde z thet
theta jeden przez theta N jest liczbą rzeczywistą, i
wrócimy do tego sposobu
zapisywania każdej z tych
liczb za chwilę.
Ważną rzeczą, którą należy zauważyć
na temat tych wektorów i liczb, jest to, że każdy wektor psi
K musi być wektorem własnym macierzy U z
odpowiednią wartością własną lambda K.
Co oznacza, że jeśli
pomnożymy psi K przez U, otrzymamy lambda K razy psi K.
Zatem to, co U robi z każdym z tych wektorów, to po prostu mnoży go przez odpowiednią liczbę lambda K.
Ogólnie dla pewnego dowolnego wektora, nie tak U działa, ale wektory własne są wyjątkowe.
I twierdzenie mówi nam, że istnieje faktycznie
ortonormalna baza tych wektorów własnych.
To równanie tutaj na dole wynika nawiasem mówiąc z wyrażenia, które mamy dla U z twierdzenia, razem z faktem, że
wektory są ortonormalne.
WEBVTT
Jeśli pomnożysz
wyrażenie U przez dowolne psi K i skorzystasz z ortonormalności wektorów, otrzymasz sumę, w której
wszystkie składniki są zerowe
poza jednym z nich, a ten jeden składnik, który
nam pozostaje, wygląda tak.
Teraz możemy zdefiniować
problem estymacji fazy.
Problem jest trochę
niestandardowy, jak zobaczymy.
Mamy dane dwie rzeczy. Po pierwsze, dany jest nam opis unitarnego kwantowego circuit,
który działa na N qubitach
dla pewnego wyboru N, i kiedy mówimy, że ten
circuit jest unitarny,
mamy na myśli po prostu to, że wszystkie
gate'y są unitarne, więc nie ma pomiarów
w tym circuit.
Po drugie, dany jest nam N-qubitowy stan psi, i to jest ta niezwykła część.
Faktycznie mamy kwantowy
stan wejściowy dla tego problemu, i to jest pojedyncza kopia tego stanu.
Dla wszystkich innych problemów obliczeniowych, które omawialiśmy w tej serii, dane wejściowe były klasyczne, albo w postaci ciągu
bitów albo jako czarna skrzynka.
I to nie jest zaskakujące, ponieważ problemy obliczeniowe,
na które napotykamy w codziennym życiu, mają tendencję do bycia klasycznymi,
bo to są
problemy, na których nam najbardziej zależy.
Sposób, w jaki możesz
myśleć o tym problemie, jest taki, że jest to coś, co pojawia się lub prawdopodobnie pojawi się jako podproblem.
A procedura estymacji fazy, którą ostatecznie opracujemy, jest czymś, czego
generalnie używamy jako podprogramu
wewnątrz jakiegoś większego obliczenia, przypuszczalnie dla klasycznego
problemu, na którym nam zależy.
Teraz będzie to problem z obietnicą i stan psi nie jest
po prostu jakimkolwiek stanem kwantowym.
Obiecane jest nam, że psi jest wektorem własnym jakiejkolwiek unitarnej operacji U, którą opisuje dany circuit.
A celem jest znalezienie lub
przybliżenie wartości własnej odpowiadającej wektorowi własnemu psi.
Sformułujmy ten problem
nieco dokładniej.
Dane wejściowe składają się z unitarnego
kwantowego circuit na N qubitach, który można zakodować jako ciąg bitów
przy użyciu dowolnej metody kodowania opisów kwantowych circuit, wraz z N-qubitowym stanem psi.
Możemy nazwać circuit jak chcemy, ale to, co naprawdę ma znaczenie pod kątem sformułowania tego problemu, to sama operacja unitarna
wykonywana podczas uruchomienia circuit, a ta operacja unitarna
jest opisana przez macierz U.
Ale U nie jest nam dane jako macierz, mamy jedynie opis kwantowego circuit, który implementuje U.
Obietnica, jak już mówiłem, jest taka, że psi jest wektorem własnym U.
Więc gdybyśmy uruchomili nasz circuit na psi, dostalibyśmy psi wychodzące pomnożone przez wartość własną,
co byłoby fazą globalną
w tej sytuacji.
I w końcu, wyjściem problemu jest przybliżenie wartości własnej odpowiadającej psi, a konkretnie szukamy
przybliżenia liczby rzeczywistej theta, między zerem a jeden, włącznie
z zerem, ale bez jedynki,
która spełnia równanie
które mamy na ekranie.
Żeby wyjaśnić ten sposób
parametryzacji wartości własnej odpowiadającej psi, a także żeby doprecyzować, co rozumiemy przez przybliżenie,
narysujmy rysunek
zespolonego okręgu jednostkowego.
Możemy umieścić liczby jeden, I,
minus jeden i minus I w ich zwykłych miejscach i rozważyć
pewien dowolny punkt na
okręgu sparametryzowany przez theta tak jak w sformułowaniu problemu.
To jest punkt, który
otrzymamy, jeśli zaczniemy od jedynki i obrócimy o kąt
dwa razy pi razy theta, więc kąt to nie
theta, ale dwa pi theta,
i innym sposobem myślenia o tym jest to, że jeśli zaczniemy od jedynki i przesuniemy się o odległość dwa pi theta po samym okręgu,
dotrzemy do naszego punktu, E do
dwóch razy pi razy theta.
Każdy punkt na zespolonym okręgu jednostkowym może być w ten sposób przedstawiony
dla unikalnego wyboru theta.
I to dlatego, że robimy
pełny obrót okrągiem, gdy theta przechodzi od zera do jedynki, i gdybyśmy dotarli aż
do theta równej jeden,
wrócilibyśmy tam, gdzie
zaczęliśmy przy theta równej zero, dlatego włączamy zero, ale nie włączamy jedynki.
Właśnie po to, żeby każdy
punkt na zespolonym okręgu jednostkowym odpowiadał unikalnej wartości theta w rozważanym zakresie.
Istnieją różne sposoby,
w jakie moglibyśmy sobie wyobrazić przybliżanie konkretnej wartości theta, ale nasz sposób polega na przybliżeniu theta ułamkiem,
gdzie mianownik
wynosi dwa do potęgi M dla pewnego wyboru dodatniej liczby całkowitej M, a licznik jest liczbą całkowitą y
między zerem a dwa do M minus jeden.
Możesz o tym myśleć jako o M-bitowym przybliżeniu theta, jeśli chcesz, i możemy zapisać tę
liczbę w notacji binarnej,
gdzie mamy binarny przecinek, po którym następuje binarna
reprezentacja Y.
Mówię binarny przecinek, a
nie dziesiętny, ponieważ dziesiętny oznacza podstawę 10 i mówię o podstawie dwa
tutaj, ale to ten sam pomysł.
Ale w każdym razie możemy
o tym myśleć po prostu jako o ułamku tak jak
pojawia się na ekranie.
I żeby być precyzyjnym, kiedy myślimy o
przybliżeniach w tym kontekście, należy rozumieć,
że wartości theta
WEBVTT
bliskie zeru i wartości theta bliskie jedynce są w rzeczywistości blisko siebie.
Na przykład, jeśli theta jest równe 0,99 i przybliżamy tę wartość
theta wartością zero,
to jest to całkiem dobre przybliżenie w tym sensie, że jest
w odległości jednej setnej od rzeczywistej wartości, gdy
robimy obrót po okręgu
i wracamy do zera gdy dochodzimy do jedynki.
Termin modulo jeden jest czasem używany do opisania sytuacji, gdy zasadniczo
utożsamiamy theta równe jeden z theta równym zero.
Chodzi o to, że naprawdę zależy nam na lokalizacji punktu
E do dwa pi I theta na okręgu jednostkowym,
i myślenie w ten sposób
o przybliżaniu theta ma sens, gdy mamy ten cel na uwadze.
Sformułowanie samego problemu,
tak jak pojawia się na ekranie, nie jest precyzyjne co do tego, jak dobre musi być przybliżenie theta,
ale to możemy dostosować w zależności od naszych potrzeb.
W niektórych sytuacjach możemy być zadowoleni z przybliżenia theta o małej precyzji, a w innych sytuacjach możemy wymagać
bardzo dokładnego przybliżenia i sformułowanie problemu
można odpowiednio doprecyzować.
Następnie zobaczymy, jak możemy rozwiązać
problem estymacji fazy za pomocą komputera kwantowego i
zaczniemy od rozgrzewki.
Nie będzie to nasze ostateczne
rozwiązanie problemu.
Zrobimy użytek z zjawiska phase kickback, żeby spróbować dowiedzieć się czegoś
o wartości własnej odpowiadającej danemu wektorowi własnemu.
Przypomnij sobie, że w
problemie estymacji fazy mamy dany opis
unitarnego kwantowego circuit dla pewnej operacji U,
i pierwszą rzeczą, którą robimy, jest
użycie tego opisu circuit do stworzenia nowego circuit, który implementuje kontrolowaną operację U, jak
jest to przedstawione na ekranie.
Jest to dość proste. Możemy dodać kontrolny qubit, który jest przedstawiony
na górze tego diagramu,
i użyć tego nowego kontrolnego
qubitu jako sterowania dla każdego gate'u, który
pojawia się w naszym circuit.
Zatem wszystkie gate'y są stosowane, jeśli ten kontrolny qubit jest ustawiony na jeden, i żaden nie jest stosowany, jeśli kontrolny qubit jest ustawiony na zero,
co oznacza, że będziemy
potrzebować kontrolowanej wersji każdego gate'u, który
pojawia się w circuit U, ale nie musimy myśleć
o tych nowych kontrolowanych gate'ach
jako o pojedynczych gate'ach, jeśli nie chcemy. Mogą być zaimplementowane
jako małe circuit złożone z gate'ów z dowolnego zestawu gate'ów,
który wybraliśmy. A gdy już mamy
kontrolowaną wersję U, możemy rozważyć uruchomienie tego circuit,
gdzie najpierw wprowadzamy kontrolny qubit w superpozycję zera i jedynki, stosujemy kontrolowany gate U do wektora własnego, który mamy dany,
a następnie stosujemy gate Hadamard
do sterowania i mierzymy.
Zobaczymy, dlaczego sens ma robienie tego w trakcie analizy, ale jeszcze zanim przejdziemy do szczegółów, możemy od razu dostrzec podobieństwo
z algorytmem Deutscha na przykład, gdzie stosujemy
kilka gate'ów Hadamard i mierzymy jako sposób
efektywnego badania
tego, co robi pewna dana
operacja w tym przypadku.
Jest to kontrolowane unitarne
zamiast gate'u zapytania, ale w grę wchodzą bardzo podobne pomysły.
Zobaczmy więc, co robi circuit.
Stan początkowy to wektor własny psi, sklejony tensorowo z zerowym
stanem dla kontrolnego qubitu,
zastosowanie pierwszego gate'u Hadamard przekształca stan
górnego qubitu w stan plus i możemy rozwinąć cały
stan jak jest to pokazane tutaj.
Następnie stosujemy kontrolowaną operację U i to, co robi, to stosuje U do psi gdy kontrolny qubit jest ustawiony na jeden,
ale nie gdy jest ustawiony na zero. Więc otrzymujemy stan pi dwa
zapisany na ekranie.
Możemy uprościć stan
korzystając z faktu, że psi jest wektorem własnym U z wartością własną e do dwa pi I theta.
Zatem otrzymujemy tę wartość własną mnożącą drugi
składnik, ale nie pierwszy.
I możemy uprościć korzystając z biliniowości
produktu tensorowego.
Mamy więc tutaj zjawisko phase kickback, ale tym razem dzieje się ono dla pewnego dowolnego wektora własnego psi pewnej dowolnej unitarnej operacji U,
w odróżnieniu od operacji NOT stosowanej na stanie minus, mówiąc dokładniej.
Taki jest więc stan po zastosowaniu kontrolowanej operacji U.
Nawiasem mówiąc, warto
zatrzymać się na chwilę i zauważyć, że stan dolnych N qubitów to nadal wektor własny psi.
Co jest świetne, ponieważ
daje nam możliwość ponownego użycia go, jeśli zdecydujemy się.
Następnie wykonywany jest drugi gate Hadamard i oto stan, który otrzymujemy.
Nie pokazałem wszystkich
szczegółów wyprowadzenia, ale jeśli zastosujesz
gate Hadamard i uprościsz, to powinieneś otrzymać ten wynik.
To jest więc stan tuż
przed pomiarem.
Możemy skupić się na tym stanie, żeby zobaczyć, czego możemy się dowiedzieć
o theta poprzez pomiar.
A jeśli zmierzymy górny
qubit lub skrajny prawy qubit, to są prawdopodobieństwa dla dwóch wyników.
Użyłem tutaj kilku
podstawowych wzorów związanych z sinusami i cosinusami
z zespolonymi wykładnikami do wyrażenia tych prawdopodobieństw
w kategoriach sinusów i cosinusów.
Konkretnie, prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania zera to cosinus kwadrat z pi razy theta, a prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania jedynki
WEBVTT
to sinus kwadrat tego samego kąta. I to ma sens,
ponieważ sinus kwadrat plus cosinus kwadrat
dowolnego kąta jest równy jeden.
Zatem nasze prawdopodobieństwa
sumują się do jedności, jak oczekujemy.
A oto wykres tych prawdopodobieństw jako funkcja theta.
Żeby być precyzyjnym, jest to wykres
samych prawdopodobieństw, w odróżnieniu od wykresu przedstawiającego na przykład pojedynczy rozkład prawdopodobieństwa.
Na przykład, jeśli theta
jest równe jedna druga, to prawdopodobieństwo, że
uzyskamy wynik jeden, zaznaczony kolorem fioletowym, jest równe jeden,
a prawdopodobieństwo
uzyskania wyniku zero, zaznaczonego kolorem niebieskim, wynosi zero.
Z drugiej strony, jeśli theta jest równe jedna
czwarta lub trzy czwarte, to każdy z dwóch wyników jest równie prawdopodobny.
I oczywiście dla wszystkich wyborów theta, suma prawdopodobieństw jest równa jeden, jak już zauważyliśmy.
Nie dowiadujemy się więc dokładnie, czym
jest theta z tej procedury, ale daje nam ona pewne
informacje o theta.
A jeśli wyobrazimy sobie sytuację, w której obiecane jest nam,
że theta jest równe zero lub theta jest równe jedna druga, ta procedura powie nam,
dokładnie która z dwóch
możliwości to jest.
To prosty sposób, w jaki możemy użyć zjawiska phase kickback do dowiedzenia się czegoś o wartości własnej.
Jak więc możemy dowiedzieć się więcej
o wartości własnej?
Cóż, jest to sytuacja, w której możemy pozwolić,
by ignorancja była naszym przewodnikiem.
Ponieważ naprawdę jest
niewiele rzeczy, które możemy zrobić.
Nie wiemy prawie nic
o wektorze własnym sin i nie wiemy też
wiele o operacji U.
Mamy circuit dla U, ale na ile możemy ocenić, może to być
straszliwy, pogmatwany bałagan, który nie pozwoli nam
zrozumieć nic przez jego badanie.
Ale jedną naturalną opcją jest wielokrotne uruchamianie circuit.
W szczególności możemy spróbować zrobić dokładnie to samo, co właśnie zrobiliśmy, tylko zamiast stosowania pojedynczej kontrolowanej operacji U,
stosujemy tę operację dwa razy. Albo możemy stosować ją dowolną liczbę razy, ale zacznijmy od dwóch
żeby zobaczyć, co się dzieje.
Cóż, to jest w rzeczywistości dość
proste, co się dzieje. Stosując kontrolowaną
operację U dwa razy, efektywnie po prostu
podnosimy wartość własną do kwadratu,
ponieważ zostanie wpychana do
fazy górnego qubitu dwa razy zamiast raz.
Więc gdy myślimy o
prawdopodobieństwach wyników jako funkcji theta, zasadniczo po prostu
podwajamy częstotliwość.
Dla każdego możliwego wyboru theta, prawdopodobieństwa wyników
są takie same, jak byłyby, gdybyśmy podwoili theta i następnie
wzięli część ułamkową,
żeby uzyskać liczbę między zerem a jedynką.
Na przykład, jeśli theta
jest równe jedna druga, to wartość własna wynosi minus jeden.
Więc stosując U dwa razy, efektywnie podnosimy wartość własną do kwadratu i wynik jest taki sam, jak byłby dla theta równego zero.
Czyli prawdopodobieństwo
dla wyniku zero, zaznaczone na niebiesko, wynosi jeden, a prawdopodobieństwo dla wyniku jeden, zaznaczone na fioletowo, wynosi zero.
To jest bardzo proste, ale faktycznie możemy uzyskać
pewne dodatkowe informacje o theta robiąc to.
Na przykład, jeśli wiemy z góry, że theta jest równe zero lub theta równa się jedna czwarta, to ten circuit nam ujawni,
która z tych dwóch możliwości to jest.
Z drugiej strony, nie możemy już rozróżnić przypadku, gdy theta jest równe zero od przypadku, gdy theta równa się jedna druga.
Zatem ta procedura nie jest stricte lepsza niż poprzednia, gdy
mieliśmy pojedynczy kontrolowany gate U, ale uruchamiając ten circuit
możemy uzyskać dodatkowe informacje.
Nie jest od razu jasne,
jak dodatkowe informacje, które możemy uzyskać wielokrotnie iterując kontrolowaną operację U,
można pogodzić z
informacjami, które uzyskujemy wykonując ją tylko raz, i w rzeczywistości istnieje kilka
sposobów, jak możemy postąpić.
Na przykład, istnieje technika zwana iteracyjną estymacją fazy, która polega na uruchamianiu circuit takich jak te, które widzieliśmy,
wraz z pewnymi drobnymi wariantami, żeby uzyskać przybliżenie theta.
Ale opiszę
to, co można by nazwać bardziej tradycyjnym podejściem, gdzie używamy pojedynczego kwantowego circuit z wieloma kontrolnymi qubitami,
które kontrolują różne
liczby iteracji unitarnej operacji U.
Najpierw opiszę, jak to
działa dla dwóch kontrolnych qubitów, a potem nieco później uogólnimy to do więcej niż dwóch kontrolnych qubitów.
Oto kwantowy circuit
korzystający z dwóch kontrolnych qubitów.
Górny kontrolny qubit
steruje pojedynczą operacją U, podczas gdy drugi od góry
qubit steruje dwiema kopiami U.
Zatem łączymy dwa circuit, które widzieliśmy wcześniej, w sposób, który korzysta z jednej kopii
wektora własnego psi, który mamy.
Zauważysz jednak,
że gate'y Hadamard po kontrolowanych operacjach U
zostały usunięte i nie ma jeszcze pomiarów.
Zamierzamy zobaczyć, jak działa ten circuit, a następnie dowiemy się,
co powinniśmy zrobić z górnymi dwoma qubitami,
żeby nauczyć się jak najwięcej o wartości theta, którą
próbujemy przybliżyć.
Po wykonaniu gate'ów Hadamard mamy stan, który
jest pokazany na ekranie.
WEBVTT
I będzie to wygodny sposób zapisu stanu, żeby
zobaczyć, co dzieje się dalej.
A zero i A jeden to bity, a jeśli myślimy o górnych dwóch qubitach jako o dwuqubitowym rejestrze,
myślimy o A zero, który odpowiada górnemu qubitowi, jako o bicie mniej znaczącym, a A jeden, który odpowiada
dolnemu kontrolnemu qubitowi,
jako o bicie bardziej znaczącym.
Po wykonaniu pierwszej kontrolowanej
operacji U, otrzymujemy ten stan.
Klasyczny stan odpowiadający górnemu kontrolnemu qubitowi to a zero, więc wynik phase kickback
można wyrazić w ten sposób. Następnie po drugiej i
trzeciej kontrolowanej operacji U
otrzymujemy ten stan.
Pomysł jest taki sam jak dla pierwszej, z tą różnicą, że tym razem stosujemy kontrolowaną operację U dwa razy.
Mnożymy więc A jeden przez dwa
w wykładniku, żeby to odzwierciedlić.
Teraz możemy uprościć to wyrażenie, myśląc o bitach
A jeden i A zero razem jako o liczbie całkowitej między zerem a
trzema, używając notacji binarnej.
Czyli gdy myślimy
o dwubitowym ciągu A jeden A zero, jako o binarnym
kodowaniu liczby całkowitej,
otrzymujemy dwa
razy A jeden plus A zero.
I rozumie się,
że gdy piszemy Ket X, mówimy o X zapisanym jako binarny ciąg długości
dwa w notacji binarnej.
Skupmy się teraz
na tych dwóch kontrolnych qubitach, żeby dowiedzieć się, co możemy
dowiedzieć się o theta z ich pomocą w tym miejscu.
Pozostałe N qubitów są
nadal w tym samym stanie psi, który pierwotnie otrzymaliśmy, co jest naprawdę wspaniałą
rzeczą w tym podejściu,
ponieważ, jak mówiłem wcześniej, możemy ponownie użyć tego stanu, jeśli chcemy uzyskać jeszcze więcej
informacji o theta.
Ale na razie po prostu zastanówmy się, czego możemy się dowiedzieć z
tych dwóch kontrolnych qubitów.
Żeby pomóc nam zdecydować, jak postępować, wyobraźmy sobie, że obiecane jest nam, że theta jest równe Y podzielone przez cztery
dla pewnej liczby całkowitej y między zerem a trzema.
Ogólnie theta może nie
być jedną z tych czterech wartości, ale jest to naturalny przypadek do rozważenia.
Widzieliśmy w oryginalnej wersji procedury z pojedynczym kontrolnym qubitem, że jeśli obiecane było nam, że theta wynosi zero lub jedna druga,
circuit ujawniłby, która to. Zauważyliśmy też, że w wersji, gdzie stosowaliśmy
kontrolowaną operację U dwa razy,
mogliśmy doskonale odróżnić przypadek, gdy theta równa się zero od przypadku, gdy theta
równa się jedna czwarta.
Możemy więc mieć nadzieję, że z nowym circuit możemy odróżnić te cztery przypadki.
W istocie
robimy użytek z pojęcia problemu z obietnicą,
żeby ułatwić problem i zobaczyć, jak postąpić.
I to nie jest zły pomysł w ogóle. Jeśli masz problem i
nie wiesz, jak go rozwiązać, spróbuj go uprościć.
Jeśli potrafisz rozwiązać łatwiejszy problem, wgląd, który zdobywasz, może być pomocny w rozwiązaniu bardziej ogólnego problemu.
A jeśli nie potrafisz rozwiązać łatwiejszego problemu, prawdopodobnie nie jesteś gotowy
na bardziej ogólny problem.
Więc upraszczaj dalej,
dopóki nie będziesz w stanie go rozwiązać.
W każdym razie, wracając do naszego problemu, zdefiniujmy dwuqubitowy stan dla każdej z możliwych wartości Y.
Innymi słowy, phi Y jest równe stanowi
pokazanemu na górze ekranu, gdy theta jest wybrane
konkretnie jako Y podzielone przez cztery.
A oto te cztery
stany wypisane explicite.
Żeby powtórzyć, jeśli
theta jest równe Y podzielone przez cztery dla Y będącego zero, jeden, dwa lub
trzy i uruchomimy nasz circuit,
zostaniemy z
jednym z tych czterech stanów, tym który odpowiada
właściwej wartości Y.
I chcemy po prostu dowiedzieć się,
który to jest.
A pytanie brzmi, czy to jest możliwe?
I odpowiedź na to pytanie brzmi tak, ponieważ te cztery stany są ortogonalne.
Jeśli obliczysz iloczyn skalarny
między dowolną parą z nich, otrzymasz zero.
A ponieważ są ortogonalne, mogą być doskonale odróżnione przez pomiar rzutowy.
W szczególności możemy
wyrazić taki pomiar, definiując jeden rzut dla każdego wektora jak tutaj mamy.
To zawsze działa, za każdym razem
gdy mamy ortonormalną bazę, i możesz to sprawdzić
na podstawie definicji, które widzieliśmy w lekcji trzeciej
dla tego konkretnego przypadku,
jeśli masz ochotę. Dochodzimy więc do wniosku, że jest
możliwe wykonanie naszego zadania,
którym jest poznanie wartości Y z danego stanu
pokazanego na górze ekranu.
A jeśli chcemy to zrobić
za pomocą kwantowego circuit, możemy postąpić tak, jak teraz wyjaśnię.
Najpierw możemy zdefiniować macierz unitarną V, której kolumnami są cztery
wektory wymienione po kolei.
Ta macierz będzie miała działanie opisane na dole ekranu,
na standardowych stanach bazowych,
i możemy zapisać macierz,
żeby zobaczyć, jak wygląda.
Ponieważ V odwzorowuje każdy standardowy stan bazowy, kappa Y, na wektor phi Y, mamy, że stosując V dagger,
czyli innymi słowy odwrotność V do phi Y, przekształcimy z powrotem w drugą stronę do odpowiedniego standardowego stanu bazowego.
WEBVTT
Możemy więc zastosować V dagger do dowolnego stanu, który
uzyskamy z naszego circuit.
A następnie jeśli wykonamy
pomiar standardowej bazy, uzyskamy liczbę Y,
której szukamy, wyrażoną jako ciąg
długości dwa w notacji binarnej.
Zanim pójdziemy dalej, porozmawiajmy trochę więcej
o macierzy unitarnej V.
To jest specjalna macierz i
być może widziałeś ją wcześniej.
Jest to macierz skojarzona
z liniową operacją na czterowymiarowych wektorach, zwaną dyskretną Transformatą Fouriera.
Mówiąc dokładniej, dyskretna Transformata Fouriera może być zdefiniowana dla dowolnej
dodatniej wymiaru całkowitego i przyjrzymy się jej
ogólnie za chwilę.
I tak to wygląda konkretnie, gdy wymiar jest równy cztery.
Możemy myśleć o
dyskretnej Transformacie Fouriera na różne sposoby.
Możemy myśleć o niej czysto abstrakcyjnie, jako o liniowym odwzorowaniu wektorów, które można przedstawić macierzą.
Możemy też myśleć o
niej jako o problemie obliczeniowym, gdzie mamy dany wektor i chcemy obliczyć wynik
zastosowania tego liniowego odwzorowania.
Okazuje się, że jest to niezwykle ważny
problem obliczeniowy i istnieje bardzo efektywny algorytm do wykonania tego obliczenia,
znany jako szybka Transformata Fouriera.
W rzeczywistości jest to tak ważny problem w przetwarzaniu sygnałów na przykład, że szybka Transformata
Fouriera jest uważana przez wielu
za jeden z najważniejszych i najbardziej przełomowych
algorytmów, jakie kiedykolwiek odkryto.
Możemy też myśleć o
dyskretnej Transformacie Fouriera jako o unitarnej operacji kwantowej, którą można zastosować do
wektora stanu kwantowego.
A gdy myślimy o niej w ten sposób, nazywamy ją Kwantową Transformatą
Fouriera, w skrócie QFT.
Matematycznie rzecz biorąc jest to zasadniczo to samo co dyskretna Transformata Fouriera, ale nazywamy ją Kwantową Transformatą Fouriera,
żeby podkreślić, że jest to operacja stosowana do wektora stanu kwantowego.
Zmieńmy więc nazwę naszej macierzy, z V na QFT cztery, żeby odzwierciedlić ten fakt,
że operacja, którą opracowaliśmy, jest w rzeczywistości Kwantową Transformatą Fouriera.
Oto kompletny circuit do poznania wartości Y, gdy obiecano nam, że
theta równa się Y podzielone przez cztery,
dla Y będącego zero, jeden, dwa lub trzy.
I żeby być precyzyjnym, stosujemy odwrotność
Kwantowej Transformaty Fouriera, czyli innymi słowy QFT cztery dagger,
żeby odwzorować jeden z czterech możliwych stanów z powrotem na standardowy stan bazowy, ket Y, abyśmy mogli odtworzyć Y przez pomiar.
Taki jest więc circuit, który
otrzymujemy myśląc o obiecanej wersji problemu
estymacji fazy, gdzie obiecano nam, że theta
wynosi zero, jedna czwarta, jedna
druga lub trzy czwarte, ale nic nie stoi na przeszkodzie,
żeby uruchomić ten circuit dla
dowolnej wartości theta.
A jeśli to zrobimy, oto
prawdopodobieństwa dla czterech możliwych
wyników, które uzyskujemy.
Każda z czterech możliwych
wartości Y ma swój kolor i wykres mówi nam,
jakie są prawdopodobieństwa dla każdej z nich jako funkcja theta.
Na przykład, jeśli theta
jest równe trzy czwarte, uzyskamy wynik
trzy z prawdopodobieństwem jeden,
a prawdopodobieństwa dla trzech pozostałych wyników są wszystkie równe zero, jak już wiemy myśląc o obiecanej wersji problemu.
Jeśli theta jest bliskie trzem czwartym, ale nie dokładnie równe trzem czwartym, będzie pewne niezerowe prawdopodobieństwo związane z innymi wynikami,
ale nadal uzyskamy wynik
trzy z dużym prawdopodobieństwem.
Więc nawet jeśli theta może
nie być równe Y podzielone przez cztery, możemy nadal myśleć
o wyniku, który uzyskujemy z pomiarów podzielonym przez cztery
jako o odgadnięciu lub
przybliżeniu theta.
Odgadnięcie może być błędne, ale mimo to
dostarcza nam informacji.
I jedną rzeczą, którą możemy
dowiedzieć się z wykresu, jest to, że najlepsze przybliżenia zawsze mają z nimi skojarzone najwyższe
prawdopodobieństwa.
Gdy mówię najlepsze przybliżenie, mam na myśli tę wartość Y podzielone przez cztery, która jest najbliżej prawdziwej wartości theta,
w sensie modulo jeden. Najgorszy możliwy przypadek jest taki, że theta jest dokładnie w połowie między
dwiema wartościami Y podzielone przez cztery.
Na przykład, jeśli theta jest równe
trzy ósmych lub 0,375, w tym przypadku widzimy,
że przybliżenia
jedna czwarta i dwie czwarte,
czyli jedna druga, są jednakowo dobre.
Więc w tym konkretnym
przypadku są w rzeczywistości dwa najlepsze przybliżenia, a nie jedno.
I jest równie prawdopodobne, że uzyskamy wynik jeden
jak i wynik dwa.
Dwa pozostałe wyniki zero i trzy, które nie dają zbyt dobrych
przybliżeń theta przy podzieleniu przez cztery, faktycznie pojawiają się z pewnym prawdopodobieństwem,
które wydaje się wynosić niecałe
10% w obu przypadkach.
Więc ta procedura nie jest doskonała, ale dostarcza nam informacji.
I warto zauważyć, że
niezależnie od theta, zawsze mamy gwarancję, że losujemy albo najlepsze przybliżenie,
albo jedno z dwóch najlepszych przybliżeń gdy jest remis, z prawdopodobieństwem, które wydaje się być tuż powyżej 40%.
WEBVTT
Im bliżej theta jest do przybliżenia, tym wyższe prawdopodobieństwo zobaczenia odpowiedniej wartości Y.
I to jest całkiem
znacząca poprawa w stosunku do używania pojedynczego kontrolnego qubitu.
Jest to w rzeczywistości procedura estymacji fazy, gdy zdecydujemy się używać dwóch kontrolnych qubitów.
A następnie uogólnimy tę
procedurę w naturalny sposób, gdzie nie zatrzymujemy się na
zaledwie dwóch kontrolnych qubitach,
ale używamy tylu
kontrolnych qubitów, ile wybierzemy.
I zobaczymy, że
uogólniając procedurę, dodając więcej kontrolnych qubitów, będziemy w stanie uzyskać coraz
dokładniejsze przybliżenia theta. I będzie to ogólna
procedura estymacji fazy.
Żeby uogólnić procedurę
estymacji fazy z dwóch kontrolnych qubitów
do dowolnej ich liczby, będziemy musieli zrozumieć,
jak Kwantowa Transformata Fouriera jest zdefiniowana dla innych wymiarów.
Będziemy też musieli omówić, jak można ją zaimplementować
za pomocą kwantowego circuit.
Oto definicja
Kwantowej Transformaty Fouriera, gdy wymiar jest
dowolną dodatnią liczbą całkowitą N.
Tutaj myślimy o tej operacji jako o operacji na układzie, którego klasyczne stany to
zero do N minus jeden.
I tutaj macierz, która
opisuje tę operację, została wyrażona przy użyciu
notacji Diraca.
Możemy też opisać ją pod kątem jej działania
na standardowych stanach bazowych, żeby powiązać ją z
tym, co już widzieliśmy dla N równego cztery.
Oto jak to wygląda
dla N równego jeden, co nie jest zbyt interesującym przypadkiem.
Oto dla N równego dwa i zauważysz, że w tym przypadku otrzymujemy operację Hadamard.
Oto Kwantowa Transformata Fouriera
dla N równego trzy.
Dla N równego cztery, co
już widzieliśmy.
I jako ostatni przykład, oto jak wygląda, gdy N jest równe osiem.
Tak jak poprzednio
dla przypadku N równego cztery, to są macierze, które kojarzymy z dyskretną Transformatą Fouriera
dla każdego z wymiarów. Ale nazywamy ją
Kwantową Transformatą Fouriera, gdy chcemy myśleć o
niej jako o operacji kwantowej.
Czasem nawiasem mówiąc wiodący czynnik jeden przez pierwiastek z N nie jest uwzględniany, gdy myślimy o dyskretnej Transformacie Fouriera
jako o macierzy,
ale potrzebujemy tego czynnika, żeby upewnić się, że otrzymamy macierz unitarną.
Czasem też jest znak minus w każdym z wykładników, ale nie zawsze.
To w zasadzie tylko kwestia osobistych preferencji, która nie zmienia fundamentalnej
natury transformaty.
Ale w każdym razie zdefiniujemy Kwantową Transformatę Fouriera tak, jak jest zapisana tutaj na ekranie.
Istnieje bardzo użyteczna skrócona
notacja, która jest powszechna i której będziemy używać
trochę później w lekcji.
Polega ona na zdefiniowaniu
liczby zespolonej omega N, tak jak tutaj mamy.
Konkretnie jako e do dwa pi I przez N, co można też zapisać
używając sinusów i cosinusów,
jak mamy tutaj. Czasem nazywamy tę
liczbę N-tym pierwiastkiem jedności, ponieważ gdy podnosimy ją
do potęgi N, otrzymujemy jeden.
Oto rysunek pokazujący kilka przykładów.
Omega jeden jest równe jeden, omega dwa jest równe minus jeden, a omega cztery jest równe I.
Ogólnie, żeby uzyskać omega N, możemy wyobrazić sobie dzielenie okręgu jednostkowego na N równych kawałków, jakby była to pizza dzielona przez N osób,
a omega N jest w
rogu pierwszego kawałka, zakładając, że drugi róg
tego kawałka jest przy jedynce.
Zatem w szczególności w miarę jak N
staje się coraz większe, kawałki będą coraz mniejsze i omega N będzie
coraz bliższe jedynce.
I teraz jeśli użyjemy tej notacji, możemy wyrazić
Kwantową Transformatę Fouriera w nieco bardziej przejrzysty sposób.
Czasem ta notacja
pomaga utrzymać prostotę, jak zobaczymy
trochę później w lekcji.
Istnieje efektywna implementacja
Kwantowej Transformaty Fouriera za pomocą kwantowego circuit,
gdy N jest potęgą dwójki,
i przyjrzymy się jej teraz. Choć definiujemy
Kwantową Transformatę Fouriera dla dowolnego wymiaru N,
będziemy jej potrzebować tylko
w przypadku, gdy N jest potęgą dwójki, żeby uogólnić procedurę
estymacji fazy.
Implementacja będzie wykorzystywać
kontrolowane gate'y fazowe, które są przedstawione tak,
jak mamy tutaj na ekranie.
Wyglądają jak dwa
sterowniki połączone razem wraz z liczbą, którą
jest alpha w tym przypadku.
A działanie tego gate'u opisuje macierz pokazana tutaj.
Są to dosłownie
kontrolowane gate'y fazowe, co oznacza, że mamy kontrolny qubit sterujący gate'em fazowym.
Widzieliśmy gate'y fazowe już w lekcji pierwszej.
Ale dla gate'ów fazowych konkretnie, tak naprawdę nie ma znaczenia,
który qubit jest sterującym, a który jest celem.
I widzieliśmy to w lekcji drugiej, dla konkretnego przypadku gate'u Z.
I teraz gdy mamy to pojęcie, możemy przejść do tego, jak
Kwantowa Transformata Fouriera może być zaimplementowana.
WEBVTT
Implementacja ma charakter rekurencyjny i być może najłatwiejszym sposobem opisania jej w prostych słowach jest podanie przykładu, który
można łatwo uogólnić.
Oto jak możemy to zrobić,
gdy N jest równe 32.
Mamy więc pięć qubitów.
Żeby być precyzyjnym, kojarzymy
standardowe stany bazowe tych pięciu qubitów z liczbami całkowitymi od zera do 31, używając notacji binarnej.
Pierwszą rzeczą, którą robimy, jest wykonanie Kwantowej Transformaty Fouriera
dla N równego 16 na wszystkich qubitach poza
najmniej znaczącym qubitem,
którym jest ten na górze. I to jest rekurencyjna
część konstrukcji.
Aby zaimplementować tę operację, musimy postępować według tego samego
wzoru, ale z jednym mniej qubitem.
A w przypadku bazowym mamy
tylko jeden qubit, dla którego Kwantowa Transformata Fouriera jest po prostu gate'em Hadamard.
Gdy zastosujemy QFT na wszystkich qubitach poza górnym, stosujemy szereg kontrolowanych gate'ów fazowych, używając faz wskazanych
w diagramie.
Następnie stosujemy gate
Hadamard do górnego qubitu i przestawiamy qubity trochę, używając kilku gate'ów swap.
Te gate'y swap mają efekt cyklicznej permutacji qubitów, co jest potrzebne, żeby
konstrukcja działała.
Możemy postępować dokładnie według tego samego wzoru dla innych wyborów N,
pod warunkiem że są potęgami dwójki, gdzie zawsze zaczynamy kontrolowane gate'y fazowe
od alpha będącego pi przez
dwa dla dolnego qubitu i dzielimy przez dwa za każdym razem
przesuwając się w lewo w diagramie,
żeby uzyskać kolejne fazy. Nie jest od razu oczywiste,
że ta konstrukcja działa.
Nie będę wyjaśniać
dlaczego działa w tym filmie.
Jeśli jesteś zainteresowany zobaczeniem
szczegółów dotyczących tego, dlaczego działa, możesz znaleźć je w
materiałach pisemnych do lekcji.
Powiem jednak, że
to, co jest tutaj wykorzystywane, to podstawowa struktura
dyskretnych Transformat Fouriera,
a w rzeczywistości jest to dokładnie
ta sama struktura, która pozwala szybkiej
Transformacie Fouriera działać.
Innym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest to, że jeśli spojrzymy na szybką Transformatę Fouriera, możemy myśleć o niej w
kategoriach kwantowych circuit.
I to jest circuit, który otrzymujemy.
Ilu więc gate'ów potrzebujemy łącznie dla tej implementacji?
Żeby to obliczyć, niech SM oznacza liczbę gate'ów, których
potrzebujemy, gdy mamy M qubitów.
Gdy M jest równe jeden, potrzebujemy tylko jednego gate'u, ponieważ QFT jest w tym przypadku po prostu operacją Hadamard.
Jeśli M wynosi co najmniej dwa, to są
gate'y, których potrzebujemy.
Najpierw potrzebujemy SM minus jeden gate'ów dla Kwantowej Transformaty Fouriera
na M minus jeden qubitach, cokolwiek ta liczba wynosi.
Potrzebujemy też M minus jeden
kontrolowanych gate'ów fazowych, M minus jeden gate'ów swap,
i jednego dodatkowego gate'u Hadamard.
Oto wyrażenie
dla SM w obu przypadkach, gdy M jest równe jeden i
gdy M wynosi co najmniej dwa.
Jest to przykład tzw. równania rekurencyjnego i
pojawia się bardzo często w analizie algorytmów.
To konkretne
jest bardzo proste i ma tzw.
wyrażenie w postaci zamkniętej, które możemy uzyskać przez sumowanie.
Mówiąc precyzyjnie, wartość SM jest sumą pierwszych M
kolejnych nieparzystych liczb całkowitych, co równa się M do kwadratu,
co być może albo napotkałeś wcześniej, albo może po prostu to zauważyłeś
w pewnym momencie swojego życia.
I jest to dość łatwe do udowodnienia przez indukcję względem M,
w przypadku gdy jesteś zainteresowany formalnym dowodem.
I to tyle. Możemy zaimplementować
Kwantową Transformatę Fouriera na M qubitach używając M kwadrat gate'ów.
Tylko kilka bardzo
krótkich dodatkowych uwag.
Po pierwsze, tak naprawdę
nie potrzebujemy wszystkich gate'ów swap, które opisałem.
Możliwe jest efektywne
wypchnięcie ich wszystkich na koniec, pod warunkiem że odpowiednio dostosujemy, na które qubity działają kontrolowane gate'y fazowe.
A jeśli tak zrobimy, będziemy potrzebować tylko
M przez dwa gate'ów swap łącznie, zaokrąglając w dół.
Nadal będziemy mieć koszt kwadratowy, ale liczba gate'ów może być w ten sposób mimo wszystko zmniejszona.
I ostatnia uwaga jest taka, że możemy faktycznie zmniejszyć koszt jeszcze bardziej, jeśli jesteśmy zadowoleni z
dość dobrego przybliżenia.
Na przykład, gdy M staje się duże, wiele kontrolowanych gate'ów fazowych jest dość blisko
operacji identyczności,
a wyeliminowanie tych,
które są bardzo bliskie, może zaoszczędzić nam całkiem sporo gate'ów, nadal dając nam
dość dobre przybliżenie.
Możliwe jest też przybliżenie Kwantowej Transformaty Fouriera
za pomocą bardzo płytkich circuit, czyli takich o małej głębokości, w przypadku gdy jest to coś,
czego chcemy dokonać.
A teraz gdy wiemy, czym jest
Kwantowa Transformata Fouriera dla różnych wymiarów, a także jak można ją zaimplementować, gdy wymiar jest potęgą dwójki,
możemy wrócić do
procedury estymacji fazy i zobaczyć, jak można ją uogólnić, gdy używamy pewnej dowolnej
liczby M kontrolnych qubitów.
Oto jak wygląda procedura jako kwantowy circuit dla
dowolnego wyboru M.
Mamy M kontrolnych qubitów na górze, które zakładamy, że są wszystkie
zainicjowane w stanie zero.
Stosujemy gate
Hadamard do każdego z nich, a następnie każdy z nich jest
używany jako kontrolny qubit do stosowania pewnej potęgi
unitarnej operacji U,
WEBVTT
gdzie podwajamy liczbę
zastosowań U dla każdego kontrolnego qubitu.
W tym diagramie zaznaczyłem to, umieszczając wykładniki
przy U w polach, zamiast pokazywać kontrolowany gate U
stosowany tyle razy, jako sposób na zarówno uczynienie
diagramu bardziej czytelnym i zaoszczędzenie miejsca, żeby
zmieścił się na ekranie.
Pierwszą rzeczą, którą musimy zauważyć
w tej procedurze, jest to, że może stać się bardzo kosztowna.
W szczególności
podwajamy liczbę zastosowań operacji U
dla każdego kontrolnego qubitu.
A jeśli robimy to po prostu przez iterowanie kontrolowanego gate'u U tyle razy, ile potrzeba,
otrzymamy ogromny circuit. Będzie wykładniczo
duży względem liczby M.
To jest poważne ograniczenie ogólnie i w szczególności ogranicza naszą zdolność do uzyskiwania precyzyjnych przybliżeń
wartości własnych.
W konkretnym przypadku faktoryzacji jednak, do której dojdziemy wkrótce, okazuje się, że mamy wielkie szczęście i możemy zastosować sztuczkę, która pozwala nam
uniknąć tego wykładniczego wzrostu kosztu.
Ale ogólnie dla dowolnych
unitarnych operacji U nie będzie to możliwe i
zapłacimy wysoką cenę
za zwiększanie
liczby kontrolnych qubitów.
Nie będę przeprowadzać
szczegółowej analizy circuit w tym filmie i zamiast tego wspomnę tylko, że istnieje dość proste
wyrażenie na stan
tuż przed pomiarami, które jest pokazane tutaj na ekranie.
Z tego stanu możemy uzyskać wyrażenie na prawdopodobieństwa
różnych wyników i wygląda to tak.
A gdy mamy to wyrażenie,
możemy je analizować i tak naprawdę to wyrażenie
jest wszystkim, czego potrzebujemy, żeby kontynuować.
Jak mówiłem, nie wejdę w
szczegóły w tym filmie, ale możesz je znaleźć w
materiałach pisemnych do lekcji i okazuje się, że to nie jest
aż tak skomplikowane,
więc sprawdź to, jeśli masz ochotę. Jeśli przejdziemy przez analizę, okaże się, że sytuacja
nie różni się aż tak bardzo
od przypadku M równego dwa, z tym że uzyskujemy większą precyzję.
W szczególności możemy najpierw pomyśleć
o prawdopodobieństwie uzyskania najlepszego lub jednego z
dwóch najlepszych przybliżeń,
które możemy wyrazić tak jak tutaj.
Możesz zignorować ten indeks jeden przy wartości bezwzględnej, jeśli chcesz.
To jest po prostu symbol, którego możemy
użyć, żeby przypomnieć sobie, że mówimy o
przybliżeniach na okręgu, gdzie traktujemy theta równe zero
i theta równe jeden jako to samo. Chodzi o to, że
myślimy o dowolnym wyborze Y, który sprawia, że Y przez dwa do potęgi M
jest jak najbliższe theta.
I ponownie, tak jak
mieliśmy dla przypadku M równego dwa, mamy gwarancję, że uzyskamy ten wynik Y z prawdopodobieństwem co najmniej 40%.
W rzeczywistości prawdopodobieństwo wynosi
co najmniej cztery przez pi do kwadratu, co jest trochę ponad 40%.
10 to nie jest zły
przybliżenie pi do kwadratu, gdy się spieszymy.
I to jest naprawdę niezwykłe. Mówimy o uzyskaniu najlepszego
przybliżenia theta jako ułamka Y przez dwa do potęgi M,
gdzie Y jest liczbą całkowitą. I uzyskujemy
najlepsze przybliżenie z prawdopodobieństwem większym niż 40%.
Możemy też myśleć o
gorszych przybliżeniach.
Konkretnie wyobraźmy sobie,
że Y nie jest aż tak dobre i bardziej konkretnie, załóżmy,
że istnieje lepsze
przybliżenie theta tej samej postaci, które leży między theta a Y przez dwa do M,
co można wyrazić tak
jak jest zapisane na ekranie.
W takim przypadku
prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania tego Y będzie stosunkowo małe, co najwyżej 25%.
Faktycznie będzie niższe, ale 25% to co dostajemy z
dość prostej analizy i to wystarczy.
Jako przykład, oto wykres, który otrzymujemy używając trzech kontrolnych
qubitów zamiast dwóch.
Tym razem
nakreślam prawdopodobieństwa tylko dla wyników trzy, cztery i pięć, ponieważ nie chcę, żeby
rysunek był zbyt chaotyczny.
Gdy theta jest równe
jedna druga na przykład, mamy gwarancję uzyskania wyniku cztery.
Zatem nasze
przybliżenie to cztery ósmych, czyli jedna druga, ponieważ dwa do
potęgi trzy wynosi osiem.
I w tym przypadku mamy rację. A dopóki theta jest bliższe jednej drugiej niż powiedzmy trzem
ósmym na przykład,
uzyskujemy wynik cztery z prawdopodobieństwem wyższym
niż wynik trzy.
I z prawdopodobieństwem
znowu większym niż 40%.
Oto wykres dla M równego cztery. A krzywe wyglądają prawie identycznie, z tym że teraz przybliżyliśmy
o czynnik dwa.
Zatem teraz narysowane wyniki to siedem, osiem i dziewięć i bierzemy przybliżenie jako jedną z tych liczb
podzieloną przez 16, a nie przez osiem.
I pokażę jeszcze jeden wykres, gdzie zwiększamy do M równego pięć.
I znowu
przybliżymy o czynnik dwa.
I oto jest. Ponownie krzywe wyglądają
prawie identycznie, ale efektywnie
podwajamy naszą precyzję.
WEBVTT
I jak poprzednio, uzyskujemy najlepsze przybliżenie theta z prawdopodobieństwem większym niż 40%.
To jest całkiem niesamowite. Ale jeśli 40% nie jest wystarczającym
poziomem pewności,
możemy uruchomić procedurę małą liczbę razy i
wziąć modę wyników, czyli tę, która
pojawia się najczęściej.
A jeśli to zrobimy, będziemy z najwyższym prawdopodobieństwem kończyć z bardzo dobrym przybliżeniem theta.
Pamiętaj nawiasem mówiąc, że za każdym razem gdy uruchamiamy
procedurę estymacji fazy, mamy to, że wektor własny
wychodzi niezmieniony.
Jest więc dostępny dla nas, żeby uruchomić procedurę
wielokrotnie w ten sposób.
Krótko mówiąc, zbieramy
statystyki dotyczące theta i chodzi o to, że robiąc to możemy uzyskać bardzo precyzyjne
przybliżenie theta
z bardzo wysoką pewnością i nie potrzebujemy aż wielu iteracji procedury, żeby to osiągnąć.
I tak właśnie działa procedura
estymacji fazy.
W ostatniej części lekcji zastosujemy technikę
estymacji fazy do problemu faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych.
Jak wspomniałem na początku tego filmu, sposób, w jaki to działa, polega na tym, że rozważamy problem pośredni, znany jako problem znajdowania rzędu.
Zobaczymy, jak możemy rozwiązać
problem znajdowania rzędu przy użyciu estymacji fazy, a następnie krótko omówimy, jak rozwiązanie problemu znajdowania rzędu
pozwala nam efektywnie faktoryzować liczby całkowite.
Druga część jest całkowicie klasyczna i w tym filmie podsumowuję tylko
podstawowy pomysł.
Ale zacznijmy od
problemu znajdowania rzędu.
Najpierw wprowadźmy kilka
przydatnych oznaczeń.
Dla każdej dodatniej liczby całkowitej N, definiujemy ZN jako zbiór liczb całkowitych
od zera do N minus jeden.
Na przykład Z jeden ma
jeden element, którym jest zero, Z dwa ma elementy zero i jeden,
Z trzy ma elementy zero,
jeden i dwa, i tak dalej.
Zatem ZN jest zbiorem.
Ale możemy też myśleć o
nim jak o czymś więcej niż zbiorze. Możemy myśleć o operacjach arytmetycznych, takich jak dodawanie i mnożenie w ZN,
definiując je modulo N.
Na przykład, załóżmy,
że N jest równe siedem.
Mamy, że trzy i pięć
są elementami Z siedem i jeśli je pomnożymy, otrzymamy 15,
co daje resztę
jeden po podzieleniu przez siedem.
Czasem wyrażamy to pisząc, że trzy razy pięć jest
przystające do jeden modulo siedem, jak jest to zapisane tutaj.
Ale możemy też po prostu napisać, że trzy razy pięć równa się jeden.
Oczywiście trzy razy pięć
normalnie nie równa się jeden, to równa się 15.
Ale kiedy jest jasne, że
pracujemy w Z siedem, co oznacza, że mnożenie
jest zdefiniowane modulo siedem,
możemy po prostu napisać, że
trzy razy pięć równa się jeden.
Teraz spośród elementów
ZN dla dowolnego dodatniego N, niektóre z nich będą miały
NWD równe jeden z N,
a inne nie. I elementy, które mają NWD równe jeden z N, są wyjątkowe.
i piszemy ZN star, żeby odnieść się do zbioru tylko tych elementów.
Na przykład, oto Z 21 star.
Spośród elementów Z 21, których jest oczywiście 21, okazuje się, że 12 z nich ma NWD równe jeden
z 21, a pozostałe nie.
W szczególności za każdym razem, gdy
mamy element Z 21, który jest podzielny przez trzy lub siedem, pomijamy go.
Istnieje wiele powodów,
dlaczego ten zbiór jest wyjątkowy, a jednym z powodów jest to, że za każdym razem gdy mamy element ZN star
i rozważamy dodatnie
całkowite potęgi tej liczby, zawsze w końcu
trafimy na liczbę jeden,
gdzie tak jak wcześniej mówimy o mnożeniu modulo N.
Najmniejsza dodatnia całkowita potęga, która daje nam jeden, jest zwana
rzędem tego elementu.
Na przykład, rozważmy element A równe cztery w Z 21 star.
Cztery razy cztery to 16, co nie jest równe jeden modulo 21, ale jeśli pomnożymy przez cztery jeszcze raz,
otrzymamy 64, a 64 modulo
21 jest równe jeden.
Zatem rząd czwórki modulo 21 wynosi trzy.
Dochodzenie do jedynki w ten sposób zawsze zachodzi dla wszystkich elementów ZN star.
I nawiasem mówiąc, nigdy
nie zachodzi dla elementów ZN, które nie są w ZN star.
Zatem posiadanie NWD równego
jeden z N jest zarówno warunkiem koniecznym jak i
dostatecznym dla tego, żeby to zachodziło.
I żeby dokończyć
przykład N równego 21, oto najmniejsze
dodatnie całkowite potęgi, dla których to działa, dla
każdego elementu Z 21 star,
i każdy z nich można sprawdzić jeden po drugim.
A teraz możemy sformułować
problem znajdowania rzędu, który sprowadza się po prostu do znalezienia rzędu dla danego elementu w ZN star.
WEBVTT
Mówiąc precyzyjnie, dane wejściowe to
dwie dodatnie liczby całkowite A i N, dla których NWD jest równe jeden,
a dane wyjściowe to
najmniejsza dodatnia liczba całkowita R taka, że A do potęgi R jest
przystające do jeden modulo N,
lub równoważnie
najmniejsza dodatnia liczba całkowita R, dla której A do R jest równe jeden.
Zakładając, że wykonujemy arytmetykę w ZN.
Uważa się, że jest to
obliczeniowo trudny problem, nie jest znany żaden wydajny klasyczny algorytm
do jego rozwiązania.
I jak omówimy, problem jest co najmniej tak trudny jak
faktoryzacja liczb całkowitych w tym sensie, że gdybyśmy mieli algorytm do rozwiązywania znajdowania rzędu,
bylibyśmy w stanie użyć tego algorytmu do efektywnego rozwiązania problemu
faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych.
W rzeczywistości działa to też w drugą stronę, co oznacza, że jeśli akurat masz algorytm faktoryzacji, możesz go użyć do rozwiązania
problemu znajdowania rzędu.
Zatem te dwa problemy są
w pewnym sensie równoważne pod względem ich
trudności obliczeniowej.
Teraz zobaczymy, jak możemy rozwiązać
problem znajdowania rzędu na komputerze kwantowym
przy użyciu estymacji fazy.
Żeby stworzyć połączenie między problemami, wyobraźmy sobie, że mamy układ, którego klasyczny zestaw stanów to AN.
Dla dowolnego wyboru elementu A w ZN star, zdefiniujemy operację
MA jak mamy tutaj.
Mówiąc słowami, co robi MA, to mnoży przez A i tutaj mnożenie jest modulo N.
I na potrzeby pozostałej części tej lekcji, powinieneś zawsze myśleć o
wyrażeniach wewnątrz ket jako obliczanych modulo N,
żebyśmy mogli zachować prostotę i nie musieli ciągle
pisać mod N w kółko.
Jest to operacja unitarna, ale to jest prawdą tylko dlatego
że A jest w ZN star.
Jeśli NWD A i N nie wynosi jeden, ta operacja nie będzie unitarna.
Oto przykład. Jeśli N jest równe 15 i A jest równe dwa, co jest w Z 15 star, to
jest działanie M dwa.
I jeśli przez chwilę przyjrzysz się
temu przykładowi, zauważysz, że elementy ZN są po prostu permutowane przez to działanie.
Jest więc zarówno deterministyczna jak i unitarna, co oznacza, że jako macierz, MA jest macierzą permutacji.
I oto główna idea. Wartości własne MA są
bardzo ściśle powiązane
z rzędem A. I używając estymacji fazy do dostatecznego przybliżenia tych
wartości własnych,
możemy wyznaczyć rząd A. Czym więc dokładnie są wektory własne i wartości własne MA?
Cóż, nie będziemy potrzebować wszystkich z nich, potrzebujemy tylko niektórych.
Zacznijmy od prostego przykładu.
Oto wektor własny MA, nazywamy go psi zero i jest dany przez
sumę ket jeden, ket a,
ket A do kwadratu, i tak dalej do ket A do potęgi R minus jeden, wszystko podzielone przez pierwiastek z R,
żeby uzyskać wektor jednostkowy. Tutaj R to rząd A.
I zastrzeżę sobie
literę R dla rzędu A na pozostałą część lekcji.
Zatem kiedy widzisz R, to jest rząd A dla
dowolnego A, o którym mówimy.
Wartość własna skojarzona
z tym wektorem własnym to jeden.
Możemy to zweryfikować, stosując
MA do tego wektora, żeby zobaczyć, co otrzymamy.
MA mnoży przez A, więc
musimy tylko zwiększyć każdy z wykładników o
jeden i to otrzymujemy.
Ale rząd A wynosi R, więc A do potęgi R równa się jeden.
I możemy to podstawić.
Ale to jest ten sam wektor,
od którego zaczęliśmy. Wszystko co zrobiliśmy, to przestawiliśmy ket y, ale sumujemy je, więc
nic się nie zmienia.
Więc MA razy psi zero jest równe psi zero.
Jest więc wektorem własnym
MA z wartością własną jeden.
To bardzo prosty
przykład wektora własnego i żeby wskazać więcej z nich, przypomnijmy sobie tę samą notację, którą mieliśmy wcześniej w lekcji.
Omega R to liczba zespolona
na okręgu jednostkowym, którą uzyskujemy biorąc E do
potęgi dwa razy pi razy I
podzielone przez R. Poprzednio mieliśmy N zamiast R, ale nadal działa to w ten sam
sposób dla R w miejsce N.
Potrzebujemy tej liczby, ponieważ
będzie pojawiać się w innych wektorach własnych
MA, które wskażemy.
I teraz, gdy przypomnieliśmy sobie tę notację, możemy zaobserwować, że ten
wektor o nazwie psi jeden jest również wektorem własnym MA.
Jest podobny do psi zero, mamy dokładnie te same ket y i sumujemy je, dzieląc przez pierwiastek z R.
Ale tym razem mamy różne fazy mnożące każdy z ket y.
Omega R do potęgi minus jeden dla A, omega R do potęgi minus dwa dla A do kwadratu, i tak dalej do omega R do
potęgi minus R minus jeden
dla A do potęgi R minus jeden. Zatem potęga omega R
jest zawsze minus jeden razy cokolwiek potęga A
pojawia się wewnątrz ket.
Nie będę przez to przechodzić szczegółowo, ale jest to pokazane na ekranie na wypadek, gdybyś chciał ponownie obejrzeć film i zatrzymać go w razie potrzeby.
Ale jeśli wykonamy mnożenie i upraszczamy ponownie, korzystając z faktu, że A do potęgi R jest równe jeden,
a także z bardzo ważnego faktu, że omega do potęgi R jest równe jeden, okaże się, że
ponownie mamy wektor własny MA.
WEBVTT
Tym razem w trakcie upraszczania będziemy musieli wyciągnąć czynnik omega R, żeby zobaczyć, że faktycznie mamy wektor własny,
a omega R reprezentuje wartość własną skojarzoną z tym wektorem własnym.
To jest więc drugie para wektor własny-wartość własna
dla NA.
Możemy wskazać dodatkowe wektory własne, używając dokładnie tego samego rozumowania. I w rzeczywistości, jeśli po prostu zastąpimy omega R
przez omega R do potęgi J dla każdego J między zerem a R minus jeden, zawsze otrzymamy wektor własny,
a skojarzona wartość własna będzie wynosiła omega R do potęgi J.
Zatem faktycznie obejmuje to
psi zero i psi jeden, które już widzieliśmy,
a także R minus dwa inne pary wektor własny-wartość własna.
Wszystkie działają w zasadniczo ten sam sposób i żeby je zweryfikować, musimy tylko wiedzieć, że A do potęgi R równa się jeden
a także omega R do
potęgi R równa się jeden.
Istnieją inne wektory własne MA, takie jak ket zero na przykład, ale nie będą one dla nas użyteczne i nie musimy się nimi martwić.
Musimy się martwić tylko psi zero przez psi R minus jeden.
Skupmy się na psi jeden przez chwilę, żeby spróbować zrozumieć, dlaczego zależy nam na tych wektorach własnych
i co mogą nam powiedzieć
o rzędzie R, którego szukamy.
Załóżmy, że mamy
dany wektor własny psi jeden, możemy próbować poznać
R w następujący sposób.
Po pierwsze, wykonujemy estymację
fazy na tym wektorze własnym, używając kwantowego circuit, który
implementuje operację MA.
Otrzymujemy przybliżenie theta, które w tym przypadku wynosi jeden przez R.
A po drugie, ponieważ szukamy R i mamy
przybliżenie jeden przez R, naturalną rzeczą jest obliczenie odwrotności
i zaokrąglenie jej do
najbliższej liczby całkowitej. Musimy zaokrąglać w ten sposób,
ponieważ R musi być liczbą całkowitą.
Ale nie mamy jeden przez R dokładnie, mamy tylko przybliżenie.
Ale jeśli przybliżenie jest wystarczająco dobre, uzyskamy R po zaokrągleniu,
czego szukamy.
Teraz pytanie brzmi, jak dużej precyzji potrzebujemy, żeby poprawnie wyznaczyć R, obliczając odwrotność i zaokrąglając?
Czyli innymi słowy, jak dokładne musi być nasze
przybliżenie, żeby to wszystko działało?
Cóż, okazuje się, że potrzebujemy dość dokładnego przybliżenia.
Na przykład, nie możemy
sobie pozwolić na pomylenie jeden przez R z jeden przez R plus jeden lub jeden przez R minus jeden na przykład.
W tych dwóch ułamkach, jeden przez R plus jeden i
jeden przez R minus jeden są dość bliskie jeden
przez R gdy R jest duże.
Ale choć potrzebujemy dość dokładnego przybliżenia, nie potrzebujemy absurdalnie
dokładnego przybliżenia i można pokazać, że jeśli nasze przybliżenie
spełnia nierówność, którą
mamy tutaj na ekranie, to zaokrąglanie da
nam właściwą odpowiedź.
Nie będę próbować tego uzasadniać w tym filmie, ale jest to pokazane w materiałach
pisemnych do lekcji, na wypadek gdy interesują Cię szczegóły.
I jeśli taka jest poszukiwana przez nas dokładność, to wystarczy użyć liczby kontrolnych qubitów w procedurze estymacji fazy
równej dwóm razy
długości N plus jeden.
Gdzie, jak mieliśmy w poprzednich lekcjach, długość N to liczba bitów potrzebnych do wyrażenia N w postaci binarnej.
Nawiasem mówiąc, jeśli jesteśmy zadowoleni
z uzyskania najlepszego przybliżenia z prawdopodobieństwem co najmniej 40% i nie próbujemy zwiększyć naszej pewności
tak jak opisywałem wcześniej, to tak naprawdę nie potrzebujemy tego plus jeden.
Ale w każdym razie, mamy, że liczba
kontrolnych qubitów, których potrzebujemy, jest liniowa względem długości N
zapisanego jako ciąg binarny.
Widzieliśmy, że jeśli mamy
wektor własny psi jeden, możemy użyć estymacji fazy do znalezienia R, pod warunkiem że używamy wystarczającej dokładności.
Niestety nie jest tak łatwo zdobyć ten wektor własny.
Zadajmy więc inne pytanie.
Załóżmy, że nie mamy psi jeden, ale mamy psi
dla losowego wyboru J.
Czy nadal możemy dowiedzieć się, czym jest R? Albo przynajmniej czy możemy
dowiedzieć się czegoś o R?
I odpowiedź brzmi tak, możemy dowiedzieć się czegoś
o R, przynajmniej średnio.
Możemy spróbować
dowiedzieć się, czym jest J przez R, używając bardzo podobnej metody
do tej, którą właśnie widzieliśmy,
ale z kluczową różnicą.
Po pierwsze, zrobimy dokładnie
to samo, co zrobiliśmy wcześniej, czyli uruchomimy procedurę
estymacji fazy na wektorze własnym psi J.
I otrzymamy
przybliżenie J przez R, w odróżnieniu od jeden przez R,
które mieliśmy wcześniej.
Ale teraz mamy mały problem, ponieważ obliczenie
odwrotności nie da nam R, da nam R przez J.
I nawiasem mówiąc, nie
zakładamy, że wiemy, czym jest J, mamy po prostu dane psi J dla losowego J,
i nie jesteśmy informowani, czym jest J. Co więc możemy zrobić?
Cóż, okazuje się, że istnieje dobrze znany
algorytm klasyczny, który może nam pomóc, zwany
algorytmem ułamków łańcuchowych.
I co ten algorytm może zrobić, to wziąć nasze przybliżenie
Y przez dwa do M i powiedzieć nam, który ułamek U przez V,
zapisany w postaci nieskracalnej, gdzie U i V są obiema
liczbami całkowitymi mniejszymi niż N, jest najbliższy naszemu przybliżeniu.
WEBVTT
To naprawdę fascynujący algorytm i jeśli Cię interesuje, koniecznie go sprawdź.
Jest bardzo ściśle powiązany z algorytmem Euklidesa do
obliczania NWD w rzeczywistości.
Ale nie będę mówić o nim nic
więcej w tym filmie.
Chodzi o to, że jeśli mamy dobre
przybliżenie pewnego ułamka, w którym licznik i
mianownik nie są zbyt duże,
algorytm może odtworzyć ten ułamek i właśnie to tutaj robimy.
I teraz zostaje nam dokładnie
to samo pytanie co poprzednio, czyli jak dużej precyzji potrzebujemy?
I okazuje się, że
dokładnie to samo ograniczenie, które mieliśmy wcześniej, działa w tym przypadku.
Zatem wybór M dokładnie
w taki sam sposób jak poprzednio działa tutaj też.
Teraz niekoniecznie
powie nam to R.
To, czego się dowiemy, jeśli użyjemy
wystarczającej precyzji, to J przez R, ale będzie to
ułamek w postaci nieskracalnej.
Więc możemy mieć pecha w tym sensie, że ten losowy wybór J może mieć wspólne dzielniki z R,
i będą przed nami ukryte. W najgorszym przypadku na przykład, moglibyśmy uzyskać J równe zero i absolutnie niczego się nie nauczymy.
Ale to jest dosłownie jedyny
przypadek, gdy niczego się nie uczymy.
Ogólnie przynajmniej
uzyskamy nietrywialny dzielnik R i jeśli będziemy mogli losować próbki
i uzyskiwać psi J dla różnych wyborów J, możemy faktycznie odtworzyć
R z dużym prawdopodobieństwem, obliczając najmniejszą wspólną wielokrotność
wszystkich obserwowanych mianowników. A to tak naprawdę
nie wymaga zbyt wielu prób.
Konkluzja jest taka, że niektóre wybory J ukryją czynniki R, ale losowe wybory J
nie będą w stanie długo ukrywać
czynników R.
To jest więc ten pomysł. Pozostaje rozważenie implementacji i w szczególności dowiedzenie się,
ile kosztuje.
Istota pomysłu, obliczanie rzędu danego
elementu A i ZN star, polega na zastosowaniu procedury estymacji fazy
do operacji MA.
Obliczmy,
jaki jest koszt tego jako funkcja długości dużego N, którą oznaczam przez małe n.
Oto circuit estymacji fazy. Będziemy potrzebować małe n qubitów w dolnej części circuit
do zakodowania elementów ZN w postaci binarnej. Mamy więc duże N kontrolnych qubitów na górze i małe n qubitów na dole,
co jest miłe, ponieważ pasuje to do nazw, których
użyliśmy wcześniej w lekcji.
Żeby policzyć
liczbę gate'ów, których potrzebujemy dla całego circuit, skupmy się najpierw na koszcie kontrolowanych operacji unitarnych.
Jeśli użyjemy technik
z poprzedniej lekcji, lekcji szóstej, możemy zaimplementować MA używając O wielkiego z małe n do kwadratu gate'ów,
używając wydajnych klasycznych algorytmów arytmetyki modulo N.
Pomijam szczegóły w tym filmie, ale podobnie jak kilka innych
rzeczy, o których mówiłem, możesz przeczytać więcej w materiałach pisemnych do lekcji.
Jednak nie wystarczy
zaimplementować tylko MA.
Musimy też zaimplementować MA do kwadratu, MA do czwartej potęgi, do
ósmej potęgi, i tak dalej,
aż do MA do potęgi, która jest wykładnicza względem M.
I wiemy, że będziemy musieli wziąć M liniowe względem małe n,
żeby uzyskać wystarczającą precyzję.
To jest poważna obawa,
którą poruszałem wcześniej.
Gdybyśmy implementowali potęgi
MA przez zwykłe iterowanie MA, mielibyśmy kłopoty, ponieważ te wszystkie iteracje MA
wiązałyby się z wykładniczym kosztem.
Na szczęście możemy zastosować sztuczkę, żeby uniknąć tego wzrostu kosztu.
Możemy postąpić w następujący sposób, dla każdej potęgi K, której potrzebujemy.
Po pierwsze, obliczamy A do
potęgi K, modulo N.
Jest to problem modularnego potęgowania, który wspominałem w lekcji szóstej.
I można go rozwiązać efektywnie. I to jest coś, co możemy zrobić klasycznym komputerem.
To obliczenie
nie musi być wcale wykonywane przez kwantowy circuit.
Niech więc B będzie wynikiem.
Zatem B jest elementem ZN star.
A po drugie, w miejsce MA do potęgi K, po prostu używamy circuit dla MB.
I to tyle. B jest po prostu pewnym elementem ZN star, więc koszt implementacji MB
to O dużego z małe n do kwadratu.
W skrócie, potęgujemy w ZN zamiast potęgowania
kwantowego circuit.
Ale faktycznie uzyskana operacja jest
taka sama w obu przypadkach. To jest po prostu mnożenie przez A, K razy.
To jest w pewnym sensie rodzaj cudu. I nie bylibyśmy w stanie
rozwiązać problemu znajdowania rzędu ani efektywnie faktoryzować liczb całkowitych
za pomocą komputera kwantowego,
gdyby nie to.
I teraz, gdy wiemy, że każda z kontrolowanych
operacji unitarnych, włącznie z potęgami, może być zaimplementowana
przy koszcie O dużego z n do kwadratu, możemy policzyć całkowitą
liczbę potrzebnych gate'ów.
Mamy duże N gate'ów Hadamard i ponieważ M jest równe
O dużego z małe n, koszt wynosi O dużego z małe n.
WEBVTT
Mamy M kontrolowanych operacji unitarnych, każda przy koszcie O dużego z N do kwadratu.
Zatem całkowity koszt tutaj
to O dużego z N do sześcianu.
I wreszcie, Kwantowa Transformata Fouriera ma koszt O dużego z n do kwadratu.
Zatem całkowity koszt to O dużego z N do sześcianu.
Widzimy w szczególności, że nawet z naszą sztuczką modularnego potęgowania, koszt kontrolowanych
operacji unitarnych dominuje.
Niemniej jednak koszt
jest wielomianowy względem małe n.
Wymagane są też pewne obliczenia klasyczne,
jak obliczanie modularnych potęgowań i uruchamianie algorytmu ułamków łańcuchowych,
ale te obliczenia
mają też wielomianowy koszt. I w rzeczywistości można je wykonać przy O dużego z N do sześcianu operacji.
Pozostaje tylko jeden problem i jest nim to, że musimy zdobyć jeden z tych wektorów własnych.
Jak możemy to zrobić?
Rozwiązanie jest w rzeczywistości bardzo proste. Nie uruchamiamy circuit
na wektorze własnym.
Po prostu uruchamiamy go na stanie jeden, co oznacza binarne
kodowanie liczby jeden, o której myślimy
jako o elemencie ZN.
Dokonajmy więc tego
zamiast w diagramie.
Powodem, dla którego to działa, jest to równanie tutaj.
Stan ket jeden jest w rzeczywistości
równomierną superpozycją R wektorów własnych, o których
mówiliśmy.
I to nie jest od razu oczywiste, ale jeśli obliczysz
sumę, powinieneś otrzymać ket jeden.
A jeśli uruchomimy circuit na tym stanie, wyjście, które uzyskamy,
będzie dokładnie takie samo, jak gdybyśmy losowo wybrali J
i uruchomili procedurę na
wektorze własnym psi J.
Znowu, to nie jest oczywiste, ale analiza ujawnia, że jest to prawda.
I w końcu, to tyle. Mamy wydajny kwantowy
algorytm do znajdowania rzędu.
Pozostała bardzo krótka część
lekcji i dotyczy związku między faktoryzacją liczb całkowitych
a znajdowaniem rzędu.
Wspomniałem, że jeśli możemy efektywnie rozwiązać problem znajdowania rzędu, to możemy też efektywnie faktoryzować
liczby całkowite.
I chcę bardzo krótko podać główny pomysł na to, jak to działa.
Jest całkowicie klasyczne. Ta część faktycznie nie ma
nic wspólnego z obliczeniami kwantowymi.
Oto metoda znajdowania
nietrywialnego dzielnika danej dodatniej liczby całkowitej N.
I nawiasem mówiąc, ta metoda działa tylko wtedy, gdy N jest liczbą nieparzystą i nie jest liczbą pierwszą
podniesioną do potęgi.
Oba przypadki, gdy N
jest parzyste lub gdy N jest potęgą liczby pierwszej, można obsłużyć osobno.
Istnieją wydajne klasyczne metody zarówno wykrywania, jak i
obsługiwania tych dwóch przypadków.
Ta metoda jest probabilistyczna. Może się nie powieść, ale
prawdopodobieństwo niepowodzenia wyniesie co najwyżej jedna druga,
i możemy po prostu uruchamiać ją
wielokrotnie niezależnie, żeby zmniejszyć prawdopodobieństwo
błędu wykładniczo szybko.
Po pierwsze, wybieramy A między
dwa a N minus jeden losowo, równomiernie.
Następnie obliczamy NWD A i N.
A jeśli NWD okaże się
być większe niż jeden, mieliśmy niesamowite szczęście.
NWD będzie dzielnikiem N i możemy po prostu go wypisać i zakończyć.
W przeciwnym razie algorytm kontynuuje i teraz wiemy, że A jest w ZN star.
I teraz obliczamy rząd A, co jest miejscem, gdzie potrzebujemy komputera kwantowego.
Albo może mamy inny
sposób obliczenia rzędu. Algorytm tak naprawdę
nie dba o to, skąd pochodzi, ale jedyny sposób, który znamy,
żeby robić to efektywnie,
to komputer kwantowy.
Jeśli rząd R jest parzysty, to obliczamy NWD
A do potęgi R przez dwa minus jeden z N.
A jeśli to NWD jest większe niż jeden, to znowu mamy dzielnik N, więc wypisujemy go i kończymy.
W przeciwnym razie algorytm zakończył się niepowodzeniem. W takim przypadku możemy
wrócić do początku i wybrać inne A
i mieć nadzieję na lepszy
wynik za następnym razem.
I to tyle. I nawiasem mówiąc, gdy
raz znajdziemy dzielnik N, możemy rekurować zarówno na tym dzielniku,
jak i podzielić przez niego, aż będziemy mieć pierwszorzędową faktoryzację N.
Dlaczego to powinno działać?
Cóż, istnieją dwa główne punkty. Pierwszym jest to, że ponieważ A do potęgi R jest przystające do jeden modulo N,
mamy, że N dzieli A
do potęgi R minus jeden.
Te dwa stwierdzenia
są w rzeczywistości równoważne. To jest definicja mod N, którą znajdziesz w książkach z teorii liczb.
Po drugie, jeśli R jest parzyste, to to równanie, które
mamy tutaj, jest prawdziwe.
Jest to dobrze znany wzór
na różnicę kwadratów.
W rzeczywistości to równanie jest prawdziwe dla wszystkich R, ale potrzebujemy R przez dwa, żeby być
liczbą całkowitą w kroku czwartym.
WEBVTT
I tak jeśli złożymy oba fakty razem, widzimy, że każdy pierwszy dzielnik N musi dzielić jedno z dwóch
wyrażeń w nawiasach,
ponieważ to jedyny sposób,
w jaki N może dzielić iloczyn.
Teraz mogłoby być tak, że każdy
pojedynczy pierwszy dzielnik N dzieli pierwsze
wyrażenie w nawiasach, a nie drugie, ale dla naszego losowego A,
to nie jest zbyt prawdopodobne. I tak, gdy obliczamy
NWD w kroku czwartym, prawdopodobnie uzyskamy iloczyn
niektórych z pierwszych
dzielników N, ale nie wszystkich.
Żeby dokładnie to przeanalizować,
potrzeba nieco teorii liczb, ale jest to dość podstawowa teoria liczb.
Więc jeśli uważasz teorię liczb
za interesującą i chciałbyś dowiedzieć się o niej więcej, spróbuj przepracować tę analizę.
Przepracowywanie takich rzeczy to doskonały sposób na naukę, ale zostawiam to tobie.
I to jest koniec lekcji. W tej lekcji omówiliśmy
problem estymacji fazy, jak możemy go efektywnie rozwiązać
na komputerze kwantowym,
i jak możemy zastosować rozwiązanie, żeby uzyskać wielomianowy
koszt kwantowego algorytmu faktoryzacji liczb całkowitych.
Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie na kolejnej lekcji, która jest o Groverowskim
algorytmie kwantowego przeszukiwania.
Do zobaczenia.